c'est qui ce mec c'est là c'est la folie
[Musique]
maxime on sait pour bien occuper de vous
dans 7 à vous avez été piégé deux fois
deux fois mon maxime il pensé se rendre
à un speed dating pour la quotidienne à
son arrivée on a prétexté un problème
technique l'annonçant qu'on n'avait plus
le retour image et en cas de problème il
devait dire poulets rôtis très
importante ou 06 vous allez voir et
l'équipe de production intervient
directement
regardez comment un moment de séduction
peut mal tourner avec maxime daigneault
c'est du très très très très lourd c'est
dans la grande race sera prêt à regarder
c'est parti
[Musique]
au mas excusez moi tout le monde on a
commencé à ses traces et comment ça va
merci sophy enquêteurs ce dos ce soir
exceptionnellement ça va être d'accord
mars à manas vas-y par an plus tôt je
suis journaliste a senti quelque chose
justement tu as fait les méchancetés
non qu'est ce que tu fous beau gosse
très très beau et très belle à bientôt
progression lundi dans une question
qui était médecin représenter ou c'est
moi qui me pousse vers la grèce aurait
donc ses matches avant tout ce que je
fais ça l'était pas
et comme je voulais dire en jeans
supporter j'étais joueur c'est vraiment
préféré un nom mais c'est pourquoi
j'étais là quand il dirige cgt choc
commence à bouger
sa créature
thuram ou
si vous regardez échoue
[Musique]
le crayon a totalement new là j'ai tant
le jeter en fait j'ai fait la
déconcentration
embêté car c'est en fait je rentre
travailler mais je sais où décidément à
chaque fois que ça donne excitation
[Musique]
écoute max et moi je t'ai dit que
c'était toi
tu peux parler du bien cette fille avec
qui je le tuerais le par les super
rallye
sa peine maximum et bonjour bonjour j'ai
rencontré michel jeu et qui dans votre
question
le connais pas mais seulement d'une
chose si c'est cela oui mais j'ai besoin
de la bombe poulets rôtis ça se passe
bien mais sauf que la fille est
complètement folle soirée normes
équivalentes à ce qui se passe tout ça
il faut demander chose avec parcimonie
et puis le programme est bon tu sais si
tu fais tout aussi vendeur je suis à toi
si tu fais quoi mais comment ça se fait
quoi et c'est ce qu'ils seront clos ces
personnes grand chose sur son souffle
pour ceux qui se moquent
c'est là c'est la folie s'est passé
écoutez monsieur c'est bon ce temps qui
fonctionne
[Applaudissements]
les messieurs c'est une réunion pour
rencontrer des amis mais le truc ici
c'est un homme l'organisation pour
trouver des m21
[Musique]
toujours écrit avant vous et péter la
gueule
à l'entrée le reste
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
franchement ça va
[Applaudissements]
c
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas autant que je peux deux attentats
dans ce soir là dedans moi je suis pas
bien dans sa peau mais toujours contre
la fuite des jeunes taguent pas le droit
savons tu dois je te jure je t'ai fait
l'an dernier
tu vas te régaler et tu vas laisser moi
ok pour voir qu'on pouvait sembler je te
le trou comme ça ok tu te balades à
cette affaire
tu continues comme ça tu revanche la
mère tape alors tu vas voir choisir
bonjour moi tu vas voir il est parti et
on va tous mourir tranquillement quand
kate
c'est fou ça va doucement plus petits
d'accord
dégagement sont improductives et tu la
sors de ton dans la principauté
[Musique]
as tu vas tu vas tu max evans
franchement moi je me sentais en
sécurité maximum multi oui moi je
propose qu'on voit tout de suite
il ya là mais moi il ya deux meilleures
phrases toutefois plus petits bien
entendu il ya c'est la folie ce krach
ses aspirations ferrer aux mollahs ceux
qui se moquent tôt ces personnes
commencent à ces poissons sont sûrement
ce qu'ils souhaitent c'est la folie au
touche pas aux plus petits on va le
revoir m françois moktar abada la porte
[Rires]
et vous a fait craquer la france et là
elle me fait peur la fille elle commencé
à pleurer alors les d'autres publics à
médina qui est formidable merci médina
et la regarder
il a un très beau dos très beau délia
vous étiez alors espinas je la verrais
bien et vous franchement aussi elle
s'appelait disait d'ailleurs beaucoup
fait après boncourt tous les deux très
honnête c'est parfait la france est une
belle comédienne elle fait démonter les
célibataires eux je sais les batteurs
non mais il ya une heure il proposait sa
balle kan avaient nui dans médée sur
tous les dossiers non c'est un truc de
fou et maxime je suis fier de vous ouais
bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]